Michael's with us in Ohio hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey how
are you doing better than I let on
Rachel me help well I well thank you
Rachel - for your Instagram feed my wife
loves it
a lot of hauntings but my question is
right now was to go hard about 150 in
cash and we've been trying to find a
house for a good long time with
everything that's going on right now I
have my wife two-year-old we have one
car but we're just having trouble
because we love the idea Dave when we
say you know you can get a great deal
during hard times and in Ohio here we're
a little bit outside of clean ratings we
just haven't been seeing that much
palpable in the market and I guess at
this time we've got the 150 sitting in
the bank I'm getting a little bit
worried about if anything that happens
with inflation because I don't
understand it that well but how do we
get a deal like what should be trying to
do if we're trying to find a house get
out of our apartment and just make the
best of I guess this crazy situation
that we're in right now yeah I don't
know that you're gonna get the best
bargain that you've ever seen like 50%
off on a piece of real estate because of
this coronavirus mess or becomes in the
shutdown's
I really don't think that real estate at
least there's no indicators yet that
it's going to suffer like that and so
you might get a seller that's motivated
that's scared right now that that would
rather have the money than a property
that they own and you might get somewhat
of a discount if you found that and so
in order for yeah it sounds like your
life is stable your income stable you
got a big income or you got a big
savings account rather your income
stable there's no reason for you to not
go ahead but but I wouldn't if I were
going to place on in your situation
$150,000 a lot of money right mm-hmm
yeah so I wouldn't take that hundred and
fifty thousand dollars out of the bank
and put it into a piece of real estate
in the middle
of this weirdness unless I did get a
deal your reason for your reason for
looking at property in the middle of the
wild times your reason for buying a
house in the middle of the wild times
with that much cash is that you got a
deal
otherwise you just sit on the sidelines
and let this pass right yeah I assume so
I don't you don't need to worry about
inflation inflation is not gonna be a
problem for you and when it comes to
your to your house and what you think of
this but this is your largest investment
really the largest purchase you're ever
gonna make in your life and in my
opinion I don't really care what the
markets doing good or bad like it needs
to be right for you guys and if you guys
were looking to buy a house and you have
your down payment you find something you
like it's in the price range go ahead
and do it if you're not finding anything
you guys like then sit on it you're fine
and so I hate the market dictating
people's decisions with a home your
situation needs to dictate inflation is
when the value or the not the value but
the cost of something begins to go up
and when people are worrying about
inflation this when it's going up a lot
all right
recession is the opposite of inflation
recession is when the economy shrinks
the total goods and services of the US
the gross domestic product shrinks for
two consecutive quarters it is not yet
shrunk for one quarter so we can't say
we're in a recession until it's happened
for six months and we're ways from that
now but that's what that there are a lot
more logical fears about recession than
there are inflation inflation is when
things are going boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom and price just keep
shooting up shooting up shooting up
because the economy is white-hot there
doesn't seem to be any end to it right
any and so you're the opposite of that
you're the opposite of worrying about
inflation right now but could six months
could could we be in a recession which
would probably affect house prices a
little bit not you probably want to
affect them a ton but could it affect
them a little bit maybe but I'm with
Rachel there's not anything that's
happening there that supersedes you
doing the deal that's right for you
and in order to do that in the middle of
all this craziness if I'm in your shoes
is it's got to be really right for me
and I that means I'm gonna be wanting a
good price if I've got $150,000 cash in
your situation and you may be paying
cash for the property huh you know it's
very possible and so you know I'm
standing here with cash I can close
Friday and if you've got a seller that's
going whoa I got to get out grunting
virus I gotta get out I gotta get out
well then you've got a situation where
you may be able to get a deal because
you're in the driver's seat and I think
having patience with this is really
important because it gives you options
you're not in a rush slow down
you're good wait for the right deal and
one of the whole lines up and you know
it's your ideal if you're forcing it
because of worries and you get earn a
hole in your pocket this money is then
then you get into trouble don't do that